fünf uhr morgens es dampft schon in den
straßen von mautern das essen wird für
einen weiteren langen tag gekommen war
muss jetzt schnell das frühstück
vorbereiten
sie hat eine kleine herberge und kümmert
sich als gastmutter um 23 kinder in
einer stunde beginnt die schule
sie ist verantwortlich dass alles
reibungslos läuft gleich wecke ich die
kinder nach dem frühstück gehen sie dann
zur schule danach putzen wir die zimmer
waren ihre kleidung und räumen auf 6 uhr
der tag beginnt es ist zeit im akkord
wachwerden waschen anziehen und
frühstücken es sind nur noch wenige
wochen bis zur abiturprüfung in china
baukau genannt nichts darf jetzt vom
lernen ablenken ist ein auge roth ich
weiß nicht was passiert ist wenn ich
drücke tut es weh was du nachts
schmerzen gehabt zeigt mir das andere
auge ist auch rot vielleicht hast du zu
wenig geschlafen
ich weiß nicht ich bin am tisch
eingeschlafen vielleicht habe ich dabei
das auge gequetscht die meisten büffeln
bis tief in die nacht
auch sus union hat nur vier stunden
geschlafen
er schuftet für eine gute karten
denn dann bekommt er einen der begehrten
studienplätze seine eltern arbeiten in
einer anderen stadt das zimmer kostet
sie 4900 euro im jahr ferien gibt es
kaum nur im winter dafür einmal nach
hause ist das hart nach all der zeit
fühle ich nichts mehr
warum das ganze um an die uni zu kommen
die meisten kinder kommen aus
bescheidenen verhältnissen ihre eltern
sind bauern oder haben ein kleines
geschäft
sie sollen es einmal besser haben sie
wären die ersten in der familie die
studierten und ein abgeschlossenes
studium bedeutet den sozialen aufstieg
natürlich spüre ich einen enormen druck
denn im letzten jahr hatte ich keine
guten noten ich hoffe diesmal auf ein
besseres ergebnis
und dann beginnt der tag von 6 uhr 30
morgens bis 22 uhr 30 abends werden sie
in der maut an junk schule lernen
ganz china schaut auf diese
bildungsstätte die berühmt ist für ihre
harte aufnahmeprüfung und ihre erfolge
wer hierher kommt hat die chance auf
einen universitätsplatz
der große vorsitzende mao wacht über
mehr als 20.000 schüler in der schule
dürfen wir nicht drehen wir sollten
niemanden beim lernen stören heißt es im
netz entdecken wir videos die den drill
an chinesischen schulen zeigen
verstörende szenen kinder die immer
wieder das gleiche aufsagen bis zur
erschöpfung auswendig lernen schüler
legen vor den klassenkameraden einen
schwur abbringen als motivation
ich will auf die universität ein paar
schritte entfernt treffen wir herrn
gauck mit 13 starb sein vater ab dann
arbeitete er auf den feldern
er blieb immer bauer seine generation
hatte nie die chance auf eine ausbildung
heraus extra nach mauth angezogen um
seinen enkel zu unterstützen der hier
zur schule geht
verschläft hat schwierigkeiten
rechtzeitig aufzustehen
deshalb hat die lehrerin seine eltern
angerufen und gesagt dass er immer zu
spät sein
sie sollten hier herkommen diesen zu
helfen und das mache ich jetzt
es klopft eigentlich erwarten wir seinen
enkelsohn aber chinas überwachungsstaat
steht vor der tour der mann kommt
einfach rein er sagt er gehöre zur stadt
ab jetzt passt der staat wieder auf uns
aus ich habe die journalisten in der
wohnung des alten mannes gefunden
ihr könnt unten warten
[Musik]
sein enkelsohn kommt er ist verstört als
er den beamten sieht an ein interview
ist nicht mehr zu denken
erbrechen den dreh ab 17 uhr 30 eine
motorroller karawane kommt uns entgegen
hunderte von müttern bringen die kinder
zur schule zurück sie hatten sie zum
abendessen abgeholt viele versuchen sich
mit kleinen geschäften etwas dazu zu
verdienen aber sie wolle nicht darüber
reden
der staat beobachtet uns weiter auf sein
geschäft hängt von der schule ab wanhua
verdient an der hoffnung der eltern
er vermittelt nachhilfelehrer berät im
live stream
die man lernen muss um gute noten zu
bekommen für die schüler die nicht mit
dem druck zurecht kommen hat er auch an
die lösung
viele kinder leiden unter stress
sie sind nervös sie können nicht
schlafen sind verzweifelt oder ihnen
fehlt die motivation zum lernen
für diesen fall haben wir psychologen
die mit ihnen vertraulich sprechen um
den druck zu lindern
19 uhr abends seit zwölf stunden büffeln
sie bereits aufgeben gilt nicht nur 16
prozent eines jahrganges schafft es an
die universität 20 uhr und die energie
ist hoch
jeden abend treffen sich die mütter auf
den marktplatz zum tanzen viele sind
hier schon fast das ganze jahr ihre
schritte sitzen die kinder sind in der
schule und wir haben hier spaß damit es
uns nicht so langweilig wie tanzen wir
zusammen und beraten uns gegenseitig
unser größter wunsch eliteuniversität
und eine tolle zukunft
und während die mütter vom erfolg ihrer
kinder träumen pauken die weiter es ist
kurz nach 22 uhr der unterricht ist bald
zu ende
aber es warten hausaufgaben bis tief in
die nacht